what's up everybody
we're pong Finity today we're finding
out if it's possible to play different
fruits let's start off with a line
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
by the way last month only 15% of our
watches were subscribers so please help
our channel and hit subscribe there's my
best line sir
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
match to three points red apple versus
green apple
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that was decent deciding points :
good much shouldn't chosen the red apple
[Applause]
[Music]
well I didn't see that coming
this is what you do when you get hungry
here in practice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
banana
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
each around the neck shot that octo
makes I'll feed him a grape let's see
how much he loved them a lot
[Music]
nice shot doc thank you also worth a
grape not bad
it's a really good correction I found
run out of grapes if you keep on oh so
now I've made a racket
I'll do pineapple oh that's right
[Music]
my technique is perfect for this
I really do
[Music]
oh my god what a mess
won by between every show let's go
[Music]
I didn't go Nick
I didn't have time to swallow the Apple
okay so it turns out that you can play
table tennis with force remember to
subscribe to our channel here and watch
the previous episodes there until next
one
[Music]